[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la cérémonie des brit awards entre dans
l'histoire pour la première fois les
célèbres prix équivalent britannique des
victoires de la musique ne faisait pas
concourir hommes et femmes dans des
catégories séparées lev ci et à ce titre
c'est la chanteuse adele qui a remporté
hier soir du grand prix le plus
important meilleure artiste meilleur
album c'est la meilleure chanson avec
pisé en dise je comprends pourquoi ils
ont changé donc ce clown et j'aime
vraiment être une palme à nommer les
baladeurs j'aime être là c'est vraiment
je suis fier de nous merci calmez-vous
apolline ça va bien se passer alors il
faut que je vous raconte j'avais quand
même que vous le fassiez ça fait
vingt-quatre heures que j'attends de la
faire et s'il fallait retenir une image
de la cérémonie d'hier c'est celle de
l'entrée de la chanteuse à marie elle va
vous faire relativiser sur la mauvaise
journée que vous pensiez avoir passé
imaginer elle s'est préparée pendant des
mois pour offrir le show le plus
spectaculaire des heures et des heures
de répétition et la bam ils ont collé un
escalier sur la scène c'est idiot
[Musique]
quand le mari officiel rentrer il faut
partir regardez quand on habite au 27e
étage le plus compliqué donc il faut
attendre que le mari
il est au bord de la fenêtre il a l'air
trés détendre quand même pas en 48
d'avis il ya un petit robot mais je vous
confirme qu'il a beaucoup de peau il
faut surtout pas formellement le mari
jaloux s'il arrive il le pousse non non
écouter l'alerté retrait des tentes
abandonnées accroché tout normalement il
appert la surêté m'avance avec le voisin
d'en bal lui tire son sein il indique
tout mais moins chez la pire en fait je
me suis oublier à cause du stress lors
d'un examen et euromed ça veut dire quoi
exactement
[Musique]
j'étais trop bas besoins des malades
qu'avez vous à dire pour votre défense
voilà la députée est leur constance le
grip qui s'en prend au gouvernement
après votre face à face tendu hier matin
avec gérald darmanin le ministre n'était
pas à l'assemblée il était en visite
dans un commissariat c'est donc sa
collègue marlène schiappa qui s'est
chargé de le défendre et dames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
d'abord pardon moi je pensais qu'on
était à l'assemblée nationale j'avais
pas compris qu'on était dans la
rédaction de télé loisirs et qu'on était
en train de commenter les émissions de
télévision alors sachez que télé loisirs
a offert un abonnement même d'un an est
en effet en réponse à cela c'est vrai
mais quand
excellente idée pour le pousse à ce
matin sur lci yannick jadot a fait
visiter son qg de campagne à elisabeth
martichoux et permettre ainsi à gérald
darmanin entre deux portes
allez-y
darmanin il ya une question à laquelle
vous avez pas répondu sur twitter une
question dit est ce que vous a donné un
petit chat le marine le pen oui on a
parlé de son élevage de chats qu'est ce
que vous a dit et mais n'a pas prévu de
me demande confiance a pas été un sujet
confiture n'ai pas eu un chat vous avait
filé à zuma s'est pas vous non non non
non surtout pas humain a priori allez on
va arrêter son n'est pas loin d'alerté
rapide et puis le footballeur français
courent juma s'excuse après avoir
maltraité son chat dans des vidéos
diffusées sur le réseau stop chatenay la
polémique a pris de l'ampleur ces
dernières heures le joueur qui évolue à
west ham a été copieusement sifflé
pendant tout le match hier soir contre
watford plusieurs associations demandent
des sanctions exemplaires les vidéos
visionnées 4,7 millions de fois sur
twitter a largement fait polémique tous
sont le jour à s'excuser je veux dire à
quel point je suis désolé pour tous ceux
qui ont été bouleversés par la vidéo je
tiens à assurer que nos deux chats vont
parfaitement bien ce comportement était
un incident isolé qui ne se reproduira
plus
le club du joueur a annoncé que la terre
serait traitée en interne c'est quoi un
psychopathe obscur et c'est un individu
qui a des caractéristiques
psychologiques bien déterminé une à
quatre principales d'abord c'est un ego
surdimensionné est ce que ce sont celles
là voilà c'est ça un sentiment de
supériorité donc ce qu'on appelle le
nazisme aimait vraiment débridée une
tendance à manipuler un exploité
manipulés voire l'autre comme un moyen
et non pas comme une fin direction le
chili dans le désert de l'atacama
il est envahi par de gigantesques des
charges textile des dizaines de milliers
de tonnes de vêtements
abandonné en plein air
parce qu'on ne sait pas quoi en faire et
que c'est moins cher pour les fabricants
de ces vêtements là de les envoyer au
chili plutôt que de s'en occuper et un
problème d' empathie c'est à dire devant
la souffrance de ses victimes absolument
pas de capacité de recul ou pour
épargner la personne qui souffre et
enfin la tendance à agir de façon
impulsive en fonction des avantages à
court terme sans se préoccuper des
conséquences à long terme
bonjour ma coupe et
non pas vous surveillons mais je
comprends c'est pas très bonne chose
voilà
ça fait en afrique c'est la même chose
le ghana autrefois réputée pour son
marché de la seconde main est désormais
ensevelis sous les dunes de vêtements
inutilisés ses vêtements au ghana et en
fait ils sont mis dans des montagnes de
déchets en fait c'est la fosse commune
de notre garde-robe
[Musique]
on a fait de l'afrique des cimetières à
vêtements vous dites que c'est
l'humanité qui est sic au met pas mais
pas les individus alors l individu 99%
d'entre nous ne sommes pas des
psychopathes nous sommes doués
d'empathie nous arrivons à réguler nos
comportements vis-à-vis des autres par
contre dès qu'il ya ce groupe
gigantesque en commun la
les capacités d'empathie de mesures de
prise en compte des conséquences à long
terme s'effondre complètement canton qu
en période de pandémie on refuse de se
vacciner ce n'est pas de la rationalité
c'est de la folie ça c'est votre avis
mais saisie par exemple aujourd'hui des
gens de 60 ans avec au micro nous et à
un pourcentage de non vaccinés par
exemple qui sont désistés 0% non c'est
le 0% monsieur ceux qui sont morts sont
en désaccord avec vous pascal ceux qui
en sont morts sont en désaccord avec
vous faudra leur poser la question peut
être invité les sur le plateau les gens
qui sont morts par ci sont pas fait
vacciner je suis colère là vous m'avez
collet relance quand elles seront
fermées un dernier raid heures j'ai
cherché notre pas trouvé c'est qu'on
l'enfermé dernier bouton 1 1 conques ont
juste
[Musique]
je parle sous votre contrôle ça n'est
pas un début de réponse est en test
micro à un ton qu'on juste c'est un
sandwich qui fait parler sur les réseaux
sociaux baptisée garde à vue parce qu à
base de poulet et d'avocats le jeu de
mots trouvés par une boulangerie
toulousaine amusé une avocate pénaliste
qui a diffusé la photo en ligne une idée
de génie pour beaucoup plébiscité y
compris par les principaux concernés
avocats et policiers comme quoi la
mayonnaise peut prendre entre les deux
commandes cet internaute même si tout le
monde ne comprend pas au début un le jeu
de mots pas de quoi décourager le patron
un jean lapoujade qui raconte qu'il a
prévu d'autres noms pour ses futurs
sandwich gens préparent un aubry nous
dit il et je compte l'appeler martin
martine aubry aura son sandwich à
toulouse pour une fois que amaguiz est
sorti j'ai envie de faire une petite
surprise parce que bon c'est vrai que on
ne refait jamais n'ont même pas son
anniversaire parce que ce qui a jamais
anniversaire elle se trouve trouver
elle va pas